I know Prasad will be trying to impress
me today but every customer needs the
same treatment so I've got another trick
up my sleeve
Angela's mum Juliana was here too
she's also a fantastic chef and she'll
be a secret extra pair of eyes and ears
probably were up against that time line
so you'll 90 minutes okay so thank you
so much we're hungry and we want to try
as much of this food as possible so
we're gonna bombard the kitchen with
orders I'd like to go for the masala
dosa the Hara bhara kabab Pikachu oh and
then maybe some flurry as well and
surely the special shot corn roll as
well please anything else you'd
recommend holiday sir
nice day sir I had was in Delhi so try
I'm on it yeah give me a masala dosa
yeah do that perfect you can complete
with Delhi guys listen yeah I don't want
any music this is a big order
manal is focused on my table but will
she pay as much attention to Angela's
mum in a great restaurant every diner is
a VIP yeah now you don't need to panic
you don't need to be nervous we're on
fire this is Prashad this is what we do
okay very very focused Media shouting is
fine as long as it produces results I
need 40 Oh daddy daddy now
[Music]
magnetics lovely hunting Simon
[Music]
the contented silence at a table speaks
volumes fantastic and I'm a half
carnivore dish after dish is delivered
with charm Angela that shoots the
cheetah and Chad are in their carry-on
back here each one getting way above the
mark amazing it just looks a brand grand
authentic and smells amazing like a
banquet this exceptional vegetarian
cuisine mom me no oh my god they're
loving the food who's missing meat not
me
it's time to give Prasad a collective
appraisal so I was a bit nervous for
about today to be totally honest Anjali
I was a few I know for me phenomenal
food absolutely phenomenal blown away I
thought you're so good masala dosa Oh as
good as the one I had in Delhi
yeah it's brilliant yep sleeper summit
the stuff you do just you know beggars
belief
but kofta with the cauliflower is just a
revelation yeah and food today
flawless outstanding lovely warm service
but we've been watching everything I
mean every table and there's another
surprise because we have an
extraordinary lady here
mrs. Harlan and his mum what do you
honestly think mom's in our fabulous
food I love those balls with potatoes
and dog everything is perfect and Bobby
the service would you come back oh yes
today was about redemption and you
certainly redeemed yourselves and this
whole experience will help me decide on
who's going through the final thank you
for a delicious delicious lunch if you
do something without door please that
alarm thank you thank you